welcome to cloud on air
live webinars from google cloud we're
hosting webinars every tuesday
my name is geva and today i will be
talking about app maker
you can ask questions anytime on the
platform
and we have googlers on standby to
answer them
let's get started
appmakr is a new g suite product for
building web applications to improve
your work
in today's webinar i'll introduce app
maker and its key features
show some apps our customers have built
with app maker
and are using to run their business and
show you how to build apps with app
maker in your own company
we'll have time for live q a at the end
our work often involves multi-stage
processes
several user roles throughout the
process for example
help desk ticket filer versus a reviewer
and respondent
some workflows typically require data
from more than one source
beyond just a single spreadsheet
as well as capabilities distributed
across two or three different
g suite or other products
customized uis and flows make our work
faster and less error prone
to create those we can build web apps
with app maker
app maker lets employees in companies
whether they are business or financial
analysts
i t developers and just anyone who is
enthusiastic about improving their
team's work
build web applications that are
specifically addressing their company's
unique needs
whatever vertical your business operates
in
whether it's retail finance
communications
entertainment app maker lets you build
applications by connecting to the data
you need to process
wherever it resides or and however it's
collected
design uis that are useful and beautiful
for users to understand their workflows
and creating event triggers and internal
logic
to take the actions needed to streamline
business processes
efficiently
many companies run their business using
well-known apps from leading vendors
for crm hr marketing
as well as productivity and
collaboration
these apps have been deployed as sas in
many companies
small and large and are used by millions
worldwide
however every company has a unique set
of practices
based on their vertical customer base
and competitive advantage
built over their time they are in
business
these include automation of processes
done manually
or using sub-ideal software combinations
such as email and tables that have to be
tracked separately
and aligned
many of these applications have direct
impact on the business outcome
as we will see later in the webinar the
steps to build
an app with app maker in your company is
relatively short and easy
when compared to full software
development the flow is much shorter
it does not require extensive
engineering software skills
and has several data model creation
tools and visual widgets
with which you can design the look and
feel of your app
there are also many actions that can be
triggered on events
such as data entry
app maker is launched as a g suite
additional service
last month while we are still working to
ensure that app maker meets the high
standards required of a g suite core
service
we launched it as an additional service
so more customers can take advantage of
the product right now
app maker is now available to all g
suite business
and enterprise customers it's also
available
to g suite for education customers
we announced two significant features at
the launch
one cloud google set cloud google cloud
sql is now supported as the default
database automatically created for all
app maker apps
but you can still bring your own
database and connect it using jdbc or
rest api
two g suite admins now have oversight on
the activity and usage
of all app maker apps in their company
at google we are committed to providing
our best available services
and principles with app maker
that's why we are compliant with iso
and we're also uh up to the standards of
google cloud with regards to security
and privacy
our product supports accessibility so
users with different
abilities inabilities can use it easily
and from the g suite admin console g
suite administrators now have visibility
over the apps running in the
organization
including owners usage metrics and oauth
permissions
expanded oauth whitelisting controls
mean that administrators will also be
able to prevent apps from
running without their approval
and distribution of apps inside the
domain will be able using will be able
to
be run using the g suite marketplace
now i'd like to move over to the second
part of our talk where we'll take a look
at what customers are building with app
maker
our customers typically build apps to
support their line of business
across verticals such as retail mobile
operators and gaming entertainment
we also see applications that help
energy industry
vendors control their plant
process eligibility across the world and
also supervise what's going on in those
plans
we have mobile operators who are
building their whole a whole
go-to-market
program with app maker
and retailers are using app maker to
create price quotation systems to take
into consideration discounts volumes
and special requirements from their
customers
apps to streamline operations and
workflows are also popular in many
companies
we see customers building applications
to do budget tracking
project management inside their
companies
build dashboards for security and also
use it for
app migration
one example to illustrate this is an app
built by one of our customers
electronic arts to streamline a critical
business process they had struggled
optimizing previously
before using app maker several sheets
were used to track
various human resource types required to
create many of their games
these human resources include game
designers or studio managers
and by checking project calendars in
parallel
humans were allocating the required
resource to a scheduled project
it was tedious and quite difficult for
ea to optimize resource allocation
to get the right person on the right
project at the right time
after building the app with app maker
the matching between a project need and
available human resources
is done by an algorithm automatically
reducing allocation errors and achieving
higher resource efficiency
in the future ea is thinking about
iterating based on
allocation optimization learnings from
using this app
and introducing it to future versions of
the app
another example comes from atb
financial institution customer from
alberta canada
at atb there is a large number of
processes that involve the customer
facing team member
sending information requests to the
operations team for additional
processing at the back end the back
office
a leftover from their microsoft days
many of these requests
involve filling a word excel form that
gets emailed to a shared inbox
for processing this was this was time
consuming and made it difficult for both
the requester and processor to
track their work some of these request
types have now moved to a google form
solution
but for ones that could benefit from
having workflow controls
and functionality such as request status
and assignments
or ones that need extra validation or
calculation
atb turned to app maker and built apps
like the one we see here
for foreign cash purchase sale request
the app gives every bank teller an easy
way to request foreign cash on behalf of
customers
and provides a way to track all the
requests
additionally the app reads exchange
rates from the atb website to populate
the suggestion box for currency
with the accurate exchange rate every
day
atp is using several other app maker
apps for their loan management process
a banker's loan limit check up a
centralized way to review and process
loan applicants questionnaire and match
the right product for them
while another app schedules appointments
with the right bank representative
at the closest branch
as you can see the apps our customers
built
are branded with their logo and styles
so they can look an integral part of the
corporate business
fun fact app maker started out as an
internal product at google
and today we have hundreds of app maker
apps running internally
most googlers are not aware they're
using an app built by app maker
as it as it looks and feels just like
any other corporate app
globe telecom is an international
telecom provider from the philippines
that has 65 million customers
they have built several internal
operations
apps that streamline their workflow and
actually
change their paper trail processes to be
automated completely
one of these applications is a travel
approval app
that allows every employee that needs to
travel somewhere to request their travel
itinerary and get it approved through
the chain of approval
within less than two days whereas
previously it took
over a week and involved a lot of paper
email mailing inside the company
another app that they've built is the
memo app which is
patterned from the memo routing template
in app maker and used by
all their employees to standardize the
memo content
and also contribute to paperless
environment in their company
they have thousands of employees using
app maker apps currently and they are
looking to expand and build even more
apps using the product
now let's take a look at how we build an
app with app maker
i'll show how you do this in five easy
stages
the first one is to define your data
model and connect to data sources
this means that we have to define what
data our app is going to be working with
and the most popular way to do this is
to import a table
from a spreadsheet which can be done
easily and that creates a table in the
sql database that is
created automatically for every app that
we start building
if you don't have a sheet with a table
ready you can define your data model
manually by defining the fields one by
one
the second stage is to design the ui of
the web application
here anyone can choose from a palette of
widgets what the web pages will look
like
for both data entry using forms
and to present data to the users of the
application
in tables and other widgets like maps
you can also change the styling here by
formatting the spaces on the page and
what the overall layout will look
and you can also adjust it to be good
for mobile devices
you can also apply your brand identity
as we saw for our customers
with html and css code that will run on
the browser
the next phase is to bind the data to
the ui elements and trigger in-app
events
this is the stage where you actually
outline the flow of the application
you decide what happens once somebody
enters data for example
and also invoke automatic actions like
sending an email
or just stitching the flow of the
internal logic
of the workflow that you're automating
once the stage is done
we move over to defining the user role
as i mentioned earlier
users of the app can be different and
can have different
permissions to do different actions in
the app some people
enter data into the app some people view
reports some other people take
actions so we can define all these roles
inside the app and once this phase is
done
we can preview our app to see what it
will look like
in reality and once it looks fine to us
we can publish it into the domain and
then other users can start using it
to start building app maker apps in your
company please check out google's
developer site
on the app maker section
now please stay tuned to the live q a we
will be back in less than a minute
i now take a few questions from the
audience first one is when will app
maker be fedramp certified
fedramp is a certification for u.s
government institutions
and we are right now in the process of
possibly getting this
next year the process of getting fedramp
certification
is usually pipelined into an agency that
does that for different software
products and app maker is
in the queue to be certified
sometime in 2019
next question can i publish apps outside
of my domain
right now this is not possible the
reason is that
we follow strict security policies with
google cloud and g
suite the way that we are going to
approach this
is to extend the reach of app maker both
to users and domains
in several stages and the
one of the first ones would be to share
applications across domain
the way to do that right now is let's
say between two different companies
you can package your application in the
first domain and send it over to the
second domain
offline and then deploy that application
in that domain
one of the other areas that we are
looking to expand is to allow users
outside of the g suite domain to use the
app maker apps but we still don't have
an eta for this feature
so stay tuned in the following quarters
to hear when we do that
next question can you build mobile
applications with app maker
so the answer is yes and we have various
customers that have already deployed
mobile applications
the way they did it is that they
designed the web pages
to fit mobile screens
and tested them and they're already
using them in production
we do not have ways to have
to support complete responsive design in
app maker right now
but what we are going to do in the
following quarters is to provide
interim stages where you can have
different viewports and also design the
breakpoints
in your screens so that applications
look better on mobile devices in the
future we'll also have
mobile specific widgets but these will
probably come sometime in 2019
next question besides cloud sql can you
connect to other databases
as i mentioned during the presentation
we support
any database that can be accessed
through jdbc
or a rest api that covers a lot of
databases in the market
and you can connect to those databases
by coding
as part of the app a service that will
access that api
so you can add access to any database
that you have
either already working in your company
or that you want to deploy with an app
maker app
it will involve coding though so if you
don't want to have any coding involved
with accessing a database
we recommend using the default cloud sql
that can accommodate any data
imported from various sources
is it possible to build workflow apps
with app maker
yes i think um we
tried to like demo here uh an
application built by
globe telecom for example that showed
how a travel approval process which is a
workflow
starting from an employee asking for
a travel itinerary to be approved
mentioning the reasons for the travel
the business need for that
that goes on to a second person that
calculates the cost of the travel um
suggested and also sees whether it's in
cap or out of cap or requires specific
approval from the financial point of
view once this is approved
a manager has to approve this and
finally
someone from the operations that does
all the travel um
like bookings so all this process has
been built in a single app maker app
there are different types of users there
people that
file their approval requests and people
that review it and uh
approve it and that's an example of a
workflow that you can build with app
maker there are many more
and you can also check out some of our
templates
inside the product to see other
workflows that can be supported by the
product
to summarize i'd like to remind that app
maker is a new g suite product
that allows to build web applications
with easy access to g suite apis
and in a built-in cloud sql database
over which you can build line of
business applications
and workflow operations in your company
pretty easily
and to check those out and try them
themselves please refer to our developer
site under app maker section
thank you so much for watching please
tune in next tuesday for the next cloud
on air
you